partons maintenant pour port cros au
large des côtes varoises le classement
de cette île en parc naturel régional en
fait l'un des plus beaux sites préservés
à quelques encablures de la côte d'azur
découverte de ce site et de ses sentiers
aussi bien terrien que marin avec
michaël darmon et mathieu com
jadis c'était un lieu de mise en
quarantaine pour les soldats qui
rentrait des lointaines d'expédition
aujourd'hui l'île de port cros est
envahi chaque été par des millions
ceux-ci galles ceux-ci se protéger la
découverte de la nature est la seule
activité autorisée et ce sur terre comme
sous la mer pourquoi était un petit parc
national en 63 aussi bien à terre que en
mer et en mer fera froid taz un
périmètre qui va jusqu'à 600 mètres des
côtes et pour tous ceux qui ne peuvent
pas suivre ces plongeurs il y a toujours
le capitaine marc abel et son aquascope
ce sont de drôles des bâtiments une
coque transparente la visite d'une
partie du sentier sous-marin commence et
voilà nos explorateurs novices qui
évolue au milieu des girelles dessarzin
des mulets
quel plus on a vu de quelle couleur
je reviens très souvent encore trop tôt
pour revoir à la fois les fonds marins
et les poissons indigènes même d'une
grande beauté
les ald les roches et les éboulis le
paysage sous marin ici est juste abordés
ne remplace pas bien sûr une véritable
expédition en plongée mais quand le
farian fatigue devenir explorateurs d'un
jour sur ce parc national enfin
méditerranée prend les allures d'une
découverte